notre proposition que nous allons faire
à l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui d'un
moment nous allons déposer ces non pas
d'instaurer une période de rodage parce
que ça ça veut rien dire de dire on va
laisser une semaine pour faire
d'accompagnement non c'est une période
de transitoire jusqu'au 30 août pour que
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont été
vaccinés premières doses au mois de
juillet puisse ne pas avoir de
restriction au mois d'août pendant le
temps où nous bénéficions de la deuxième
dose c'est une question de cohérence de
logique et de respect des libertés de
chacun d'autres orages et la vaccine a
donc lavé des coûts 30 août tout le
monde ne sera pas dans le respect du
passani terre c'est ça que vous êtes en
train de dire ce que nous disons c'est
que entre aujourd'hui et le 30 août
il faut permettre à celles et ceux qui
n'ont eu qu'une seule dose parce qu'ils
n'ont pas eu le temps de faire la
deuxième dose de pouvoir avoir accès aux
parcs de loisirs au cinéma au théâtre au
restaurant au café et ensuite le 30 août
se passe s'imposera à tout le monde
voilà parce que comme le président a
parlé que le 12 juillet la vérité c'est
quoi c'est qu'il ya un défaut
d'anticipation du gouvernement ce défaut
d'anticipation ce n'est pas aux français
de le supporter c'est la responsabilité
du gouvernement
je donne nous devons faire la
distinction entre ceux qui manifestent
avec l'étoile jaune et ceux qui ont des
doutes des interrogations sur les effets
à long terme du vaccin
ce sont ces indécis là ils sont 19
millions de français c'est à ses 19
millions de français que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui sauf s'adresser en rassurant
en apportant des années en convainquant
les français parce que moi je comprends
qu'on ait des doutes et interrogations
je respectais brion de tout le monde il
ya un point qui n'est pas acceptable
ce sont ces manifestations qui dérive
comme le port de l'étoile jaune
aujourd'hui est ce qu a eu des campagnes
de vaccination positif du gouvernement
quasiment pas est ce que le psychodrame
de l'astra zeneca n'a pas laissé des
traces dans la tête des français bien
sûr vous savez mon les jeunes il me pose
une question très simple ne lisent
moi je veux bien me faire vacciner mais
quand je fais le rapport coût avantage
la question que je me pose c'est est-ce
que si je me fais vacciner aujourd'hui
dans dix ans je vais pas par exemple
développer un cancer ni aux vaccins et
là il n'y a pas de réponse
et c'est là dessus qu'il faut apporter
des réponses concrètes dont on a besoin
de rassurer moi je suis pour le vaccin
je crois en la médecine je crois en
progrès je crois en la recherche
médicale et j'étais je pense que dans le
pays de pasteur
on doit aller sur cette vaccination
généralisée pour le plus grand nombre
pour protéger et trouver l'unité
collective mais maintenant ensuite quand
vous avez des irréductibles en face de
vous eh bien ils font le choix de pas se
faire vacciner mais ensuite ils en
subiront
un certain nombre de conséquences pour
les plus radicalisées des extrémistes
d'entre eux mais encore une fois je veux
pas que le problème c'est qu'on fracturé
la société française entre les pour et
les contres vaccin la vérité aujourd'hui
c'est qui est un chemin d'équilibré à
trouver